[Music]
who does raven or master raven what is
the name of that company i thought it
was i thought it was like they got high
wasn't it called just the organization
or something yeah it was i thought it
was like the organization i thought they
were also hired by
in nc5 they weren't hired by a g corp to
it's not g corp it's not g court because
g corp was with kazia master raven and
raven i know for a fact that the first
raven that was introduced is not like
the raven he's a raven and master raven
is the leader the boss of all the ravens
so even the raven they work for i
thought they were just like independent
like basically there's independent
assassin contractors right i don't know
who they were i can't stay off top of my
head what i work for in the tekken store
it was very mysterious i'll say that
yeah but i know that the raven that was
first introduced in tekken 5 had like
kunai's had the short hair
but
but
um master raven who was introduced in
tekken 7 had the sword was the leader of
said ravens and absolutely cool as hell
too
i'm not comfortable answering if we
don't know the name of the organization
i don't name an organization either i i
think it's the organization all i heard
remember is mysterious organization they
didn't do [ __ ] in other games they
didn't it was only tekken 5. who do
master raven and raven work for oh man
the two of the most
mysterious characters in the game i
guess they work for a mysterious
organization they're reporting
everything that's happening in the world
like the first glimpse that we saw of
raven was in tekken 5 where he just
simply reported into his comms he was
like
heihachi mishima is dead and he was out
and when he walked off remember what
happened the jack was there to try to
grab him i just remembered this that's
true and he disappeared he disappeared
and cut it in half and it like blew up
yeah i remember i
absolutely remember that and he was
upside down on that jet too yeah that
was sick i just remembered six yeah
uh yeah i mean he's always been an
anomaly i mean i think i feel like
they're information brokers this is my
take they're information brokers and
they work with the different
organizations around the world feeding
information to them obviously these guys
are all about intel ninjas man the
ninjas they're all about they're high
tech ninjas these are these are extra
broken ninjas can we talk about not only
so raven we we knew about raven in
tekken 5 he was involved but when master
raven came in tekken 7 seeing that just
the name master even made you wonder but
then you find out that master raven was
the leader of the raven group right and
that the raven that we saw before wasn't
was just a small fry that's crazy to me
that's actually sick because this
character that came in it was a ninja
like the full-blown disappearing
techniques and it was really really dope
and then they bring in the leader of the
ravens who has like a sword
just actually teleports like that was
another thing there was a difference
between them like they one literally
used like smoke techniques but one
literally just teleported or made like
doppelgangers raven has a special place
in my heart because the first time i've
experienced raven especially going
through the story mode in the game but
also playing the game in the arcade when
tekken 5 first came out
was raven was introduced on the moonlit
wilderness stage
and you can imagine already how epic and
how iconic seeing that character in
motion is for me and i think again
synonymous with you know just all the
epic stuff that happened in second five
not only the intro song in that game was
so cool the intro was epic but seeing
raven and seeing like a real ninja style
character very different from yoshimitsu
very different it was so iconic at the
time i don't know who they work for i
don't know what they do but man they
deal out a lot of cool [ __ ] i'll tell
you that it looks damn cool i can tell
you that right now
[Music]
you